well if you still question how far left
Democrats are going listen to this
the left's green New Deal is filled with
unrealistic proposals that include 100%
clean and renewable energy
eliminating gas-powered engines like
cars making air travel obsolete
retrofitting all existing buildings and
economic security for all even those who
are unwilling to work self-proclaimed
Democratic socialists Occident
Alexandria Casa Cortez explains her plan
listen to this today is also the day
that we choose to assert ourselves as a
global leader in transitioning to a
hundred percent renewable energy and
charting that path this is such a major
watershed moment and I am so incredibly
excited that we are going to transition
this country into the future and we are
not going to be dragged behind by our
past so there's that and check out how
Democrats are hailing this dream deal
enjoy a courtesy of Cory Booker and
there's a lot of people now that are
blowing back on the Green Deal they're
like oh it's in practical oh it's too
expensive oh it's all of this if we used
to govern our dreams that way we would
have never gone to the moon and when the
planet has been in peril in the past who
came forward to save Earth from the
scourge of Nazi totalitarian regimes we
came forward alright so what I'm gonna
start with you how does this so we've
had a handful of Democratic contenders
for 2020 a sign on to this and say that
they endorsed it how does this help
Democrats in any way in trying to
reconnect with some of these Rust Belt
states particularly when you're talking
about eliminating their major sources
event of electricity in these states I
think that you have and I think this is
why you have nine of the candidates for
president and sixty members of the house
sign on lisa is because they see that
it's politically resonates with people
who said you know they we've been doing
nothing I think it was just states are
in the Midwest yeah hold on I'll explain
I think yesterday there was a report
that we just had the five hottest years
in the history of recorded history of
the planet and so I think people are
concerned remember this is a resolution
this is not even a piece of legislation
she doesn't matter it
doesn't matter because she is in bowls
croaks saying and this is what cory
booker was saying here is where we
should be thinking in order to innovate
to deal with these issues going forward
and in fact what we know about things
like cap and trade and alternate energy
sources is that it it's economically
feasible it generates jobs so Dana what
do you make of this because there's
reports that the Trump campaign is
ecstatic over this the fact that so many
Democratic hopefuls have signed onto
this what do you make of what well I
think that their slogan could instead of
hope and change it could be the triumph
of Hope over experience because they
know that it's a pipe dream but the
thing is if you don't sign on to the
dream then you're like old establishment
guy they're against pipes too and that
well look like there's they're believing
there are plenty of them especially the
younger people they're trying to get
them all energizing excited but they pay
no political price within the Democratic
Party for signing on to this dream if
when it gets to the general election yes
probably but this to me was not about
environmentalism
it's about progressivism because you add
in all the other things health care
education etc and it's not the taxes
aren't the problem
physics are the problem because if you
could figure out a way to not have
fossil fuels we would have done that by
now the physics just aren't there yet
and I know you want to go the nuclear
part of her deal well I should say ed
Marquis as well who should probably know
better as he was the senior guy on
energy and the initial document said
they're gonna get rid they're gonna do
all of this in 10 years get off fossil
fuels go completely renewable without
the help of nuclear energy
there is no same scientist on the planet
who says that that is possible crime so
they change the document read money
economic security provide for those
unable or unwilling to work banned meat
healthy food for everyone provide job
training and education for all what plan
is this person on what about capitalism
what about thriving I mean why do I want
one dream why do I want one path what
what country what society has ever
provided all these things why is that
even a goal well and Greg about
capitalism America is already leading
the world and reducing carbon emission
so why do we need an entire government
up here
essentially everything cuz we're evil
that's the point we are evil the fact is
the under law it's about an underlying
shift
it's the fascist dream from taking away
from the decentralized individual and
handing power to a centralized force of
government which can only exist with
force this is a fantasy that requires an
army because you're going to have to
enforce this on people I think the plan
will work by the way all you need is the
Iron Man suit of armor the Star Trek
transporter and the invisible cloak from
Harry Potter and I think this could work
but this is this is what you said this
it's not about the climate it's about a
power grab and it's about taking it away
from the individual you can't drive you
can't fly but guess who still has the
power that's people in charge they'll
still fly they'll still drive because
they're more important than the public
so they'll take it from everybody if you
go to any socialist country the
socialist leaders still got the goods
right they still got the goods and
they'll fly in their private jets well
we'll end it there because I like that
point and it's my